yeah look I think today's report
hopefully
um you know it's a voice of all the 4
000 people that have built up the
courage to speak to the commission uh
and you know even those suffering in
silence I just hope that this provides
some sort of closure for them if it
wasn't for your uh bravery as we know
um this might never have been Unearthed
how does that make you feel
well look this report this commission
was set up before I spoke out it was on
the back of uh you know about lives
matter George Floyd's murder so you know
it was already set up look I think from
my point of view I was just trying to
speak of my experiences and you know if
they've played a small part in um you
know in helping Cricket see well mirror
to what it is then you know um I'm
hopefully putting a small part in that
I'm proud of that
up 44 recommendations
um in total including a racial literacy
match fees for England men and women to
be made equal immediately uh
participation in Talent Pathways should
be made free of direct costs charged by
the counties and lots and lots of others
as I said 44 in total
um what do you feel is the most
important one
yeah I think look the thing that stuck
out to me was I think of the starting
point look the apology was I think one
of them uh and put ECB to apologize I
think that's a good start
um but I think it's the regulatory stuff
um you know the regulator and promoter
um confusion that the that you know
that's there that needs to be changed we
need an independent regulator and I
think you know there's stuff around uh
you know making kits and coaching free
for kids that come into the pathway and
the pay structure with uh women's
Cricket
um you know even when I was briefed
yesterday I wasn't aware that England
women have not played a test match at
lodge uh and that's wrong
um and that needs to change immediately
with this openness do you think more
people will now come forward and talk
about their experiences
um look I think naturally people will
you know feel uh braver to uh do that
and I hope you know they do
um but ultimately speaking out is uh
difficult
um you know I'm not hiding away from
that but you know if they do want to do
that you know I'll be there to support
them
um if they asked yeah if they asked for
your help directly and I'm talking more
now about the ECB uh would you be
willing to help shape the future of uh
English and Welsh cricket
yeah look actually yesterday I um you
know I'm really concerned about the
direction uh that Cricket goes in um and
I've already seen a lot of PR
initiatives and you know uh it's a
complex space where which with people
using it for their interests so you know
I was I spoke to the ECB leadership
yesterday and said uh I would be willing
to help in the strategy part
um because you know it's far too
important that uh the game Guess is
right
yeah I I do have to ask you azim and I
know you'll forgive me for bringing this
up but I need to ask you about you know
some of the allegations against you I
know that you've apologized haven't you
about those anti-semitic posts that you
made in the past and
um you were formally reprimanded I think
I'm writing saying for racist and
discriminatory conduct do you feel that
you've done enough now or just is that
ongoing to engage with the Jewish
community
yeah look from my point of view I've
been very clear from the offset um you
know it's I apologize for it but that
was only the start uh you know I I
continue to have good dialogue with the
Jewish Community uh and you know uh
there are events and stuff that I do go
to but that's that's not enough uh you
know I'm I'm still on education I'm
learning I'm you know I'm proud of
what's come out of it you know I've made
friends for life uh and you know
hopefully that will only flourish uh as
I move forward in my life
you felt that this anti-semitic language
was stuff that you learned in the
dressing rooms of England's youth
cricket teams um did you tell the
investigators at the time that that's
that's where this language had come from
yeah look when I when I first heard
about it it was uh you know when it was
uh two days after dcms and initially it
was very much you know I came as a shock
to me but uh you know one thing I wanted
to make sure is that I apologize
properly uh and then went further in
terms of you know then I went searching
to see why I might have made that
comments and you know it came that you
know around that time when I played
things online teams that you know this
term was brought into our dressing room
uh and it was prevalent
um but you know in a way I sort of
backed up my own allegations by uh you
know by my behavior and it's something
I'm deeply sorry for and you know always
try and do whatever I can to you know uh
apologize to the Jewish community
and do you think the ECB needs to
investigate further anti-Semitism
um in the dressing room
I think discrimination of all all types
uh absolutely I I hope that this report
has done that uh in its entirety and you
know hopefully people have um you know
come forward and talked about any type
of discrimination that they might have
uh experienced um I think it's really
important that you know everything is
looked at properly and it's only then we
can reset uh and you know plan A Way
Forward yeah I suppose I'm asking you
specifically though in this question
about whether they should be
investigating anti-Semitism in the
dressing room
yeah look absolutely I think for me any
discrimination it needs to be
investigated and make sure that we get
the true picture before we try and build
solutions for it um and you know if
that's happening uh currently at
different places then it needs to be
investigated and dealt with just like
any other forms of discrimination do you
think it still is
I mean I've not been in a cricket
environment for a few years now so it's
you know it's difficult for me to say
um I've had you know a lot of contact uh
from people up and down the country
um anti-Semitism is not something that
has been that has been brought to me but
um you know all of the types of
discriminations have been
um and you know it's difficult for me to
comment on something that you know I'm
not part of okay it's um it's good of
you to take the time to join us today
from Dubai thank you
thanks here thank you